AaaaaaIright Iet's get into this game
Oh Wow
The Great Outdoors
(scream from "Won't Get Fooled Again")
I think I'll stay inside
thank you very much
weIp
I guess there's no choice
I have to go Outside
There's no Internet(Nightmare)
I must go to my neighbours(Still Nightmare)
This is a reaIIy great game so far(We know Pewds)
Let's Goooo
to our neighbors and ask for their Wifi
Oh, the door's open
WeII don't mind if I Iet myseIf in
WAT?!?
..I think a demon Iives in here..(Ofc)
that's cooI
(prepare for jump scare)
As Iong as they have Wifi..OH!
Oh..
..wow..
I've heard great things about this game
but I reaIIy gonna say that..
get rekt
you know I get it..
I get it
you don't want me to steal Wifi
I can respect
THAT
but that's not gonna stop me from getting that Wifi
There he is..
That's..
Son of a bitch!
He's Italiano!!
Those estupido vaffanculo Italiano...
..I need to get to that room..
Let's get to the back door..
Oh..
..could this be a point of entry perhaps..
Oh yes
the Wifi will be mine
hue hue hue
I'm in
(okay)
(what do we got)
Hello?
that's a lot of shampoo for 1 man
something is wrong here
something is clearly wrong
woah.. this is creepy
Where is he?
WHERE is he?
(prepare for another one)
video surv--
*BEEEEEEEEP*
Oh shi- (here)
Oh shi- (it)
Oh shi- (comes)
#RIPearphoneUsers
FUCK
YE-sus
CHRIST!
wHaTs ThE MaTeR WiTh Mah nEiHbOur!?!
I WILL GET HIS WIFI!
New attempt(Failed)
let's NOT walk in front of the
surveillance system this time
okay
alright
he's got:
Chinese Food
and Daaaaaaaaaaa
He likes boys
that's alright
So do I
What do we have in the fridge?
Who keeps apples in their fridge??
Somethings clearly not right in here..
I NEED THAT WIFI DAMMIT!
it must be here somewhere..
where's the damn wifi..
(prepare to get rekt pewds)
Oh shit..
(door opens)
Oh..
(condolence)
NO!
AHHHH!!
JESUS
CHRIST
JESUS!
CHRIST!
why am i scared while playing this game?(Its a horor game...)
it doesn't make AAANY fucking sense
for the 5th time..
..I'm gonna get that wifi..
here we go
(Nice work pewds)
oh
Aw, no!
NO!
I'm stuck again..(Fantastic)
shit he's coming out!
Aw fuck
FUCK
what did i do??
(torturing the keyboard)
COME ON!
(waiting to be captured.... ..again)
WTF is this game..
it's soo weird..
WHY AM I STALKING MY NEIGHBOR??
IT'S DOESN'T MAKE AANY SENSE!
HEYYYY!!!!!
ITS PWED!!
TOP OF THE-
- MORNIN' TO YA -
LADDIE!!
well if he can't hear that..
he must be deaf
Somebody once
told me, the world is g-
there's a bucket trap..
(yep, he FELL for it)
the FAMOUS bucket trap
what the-
(Beartrapped)
Ah shit, I fell in the bucket trap
Aw, IT'S THE BEARTRAP AGAIN!
NO!
NO!!
NO!!!
NO!
NO!!
AHHHHHHHHHHHHHH!!!!!!!
Why am I scared of him?!?
a'right, so there is a room..
..that I need to get into..
.. but there's a passcode..
.. and I need to get through..
( ( ( ( ( ( ( ( ( ( ( ( ( CHEATER ) ) ) ) ) ) ) ) ) ) ) )
Hopefully I can do it
without stepping on a fucking beartraps
(prepare for jumpscare)
where is he?..
is thi-
AAAHHH!! (closes the game)
Fuck I.. shit (WinXP??)
I fucking quit the game
Cheesus chriist
DAAAMN IT!!
I can do dis
shu-
shut up.. I can do dis
I know what I am doing(We know...)
SsSTAAHP IT!!
I don't see him
you know, it bothers me that i cant see him..
Hello?
let's just walk slowly
very slowly
slowly
OH MY GOD!
it's the illuminati!(6666666666666666666)
I KNEW IT!!
(he dropped something)
JESUS CHRIST! WHAT WAS THAT?!?
Hello?
mister neighbuh?
it's poodeepay here!
your good ol' neighbor..
(jumpscare in 3..)
pls do not
fuck me..
takin' in-
UUUHHHH!!
where does he come from?!?
you know what..
I'm fooking pissed NOW!
HEY YOU ITALIAN SCUM I'M COMING FOR YOU!
let's try and go upstairs
Oh my god..
let's not go upstairs
THAT'S the room we need to get into..
ok, alright..
(BEARTRAPPED)
SHIT!
How do I get out of the beartraps?!?
*GASP* I'm FREE!!
I'm free of the beartrap!!
(but not from him)
Shit, what do i do now?!?
TAAAAKE DA BOOOXXX!!
TAKE DA BOOOoooxxxx...
I'm soo bad at this game, it's painful
HEY BUDDY!!
you want a b-(screams)
Joe?!?
why am i so scared of this stupid ass
stupid game, I'm not sca-
SHUT UP! I'm not scared..
(Really?!?)
stupid SOUND!
it's just the sound!
he's just an italian guy..
I'm not scared of italian man..(You are scared of Marzia)
stoopid everyone
fuhking hate dis fuhking game..
HEY!! FUCKING A-
Oh.. he locks his door now..
what a DIIIICCCK!!
take a box!
Oh shit! I broke his house!!
RUN TO MY HOUSE!!
RUN TO MY
HOOOOOUSE!!
YOU CANT COME TO MY HOUSE!!
he cant come to my house, can he?
HA!
(laughs maniacally)
thats fucking right!
MA house!
My fucking house..
NNNNNOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO!!
Oh that's right!! you cant get-
(shocked)
HE THREW A BEARTRAP AT ME!
HE THREW APPLES (tomatoes) AT ME!!
HEY!
LISTEN HERE YOU FUC-
AW shit
damn it!
well, its back to 2015 pewdiepie
just screaming at video games WOW!
(shocked by titan neighbor)
Alright, this has been a GREAT game, thank you..
Gobble will now take over..(FINALLY)
go ahead gobble..
[oh my god.. he's coming for me pewds]
ok, gobble jeesus
(indistinctive chat that he didn't
have any progress in this game)
I'll play, you direct me
Mike: ok, you have to go nex- ne..
next to his TV, there is a key..
Pewds: his TV?!?
Mike: yeah
Pewds: HE JUST BROKE INTO HIS OWN HOUSE!
Did you see that?!?
Mike: yeah, I saw it..
Pewds: It's perfect, ok what do I need?
Mike: there's should be a key..
(prepare for jumpscare)
Pewds: Oh shit, where??
Mike: there
OH SHIT, FUCKING SHIT!
I hate this game!
MICHAEL!
Mike: I'm sorry..
Do something!
Oh shit, I hear him, I hear him, I hear him
shut up!
SHUT UP!
SHIT!
(footsteps)
Mike whispers: get the hammer
THE HAMMER?!?
(there's a hammer)
Where's the hammer?
(in the boiler room, have you seen where the-)
THERE'S NO BOILER ROOM!
Where do I go michael?
(back of the-)
I'M IN THE BACK OF THE HOU-
Oh you mean this..
(yeah)
There's a beartrap
(there should be ah...)
(a hammer somewhere)
Ah shit, where
Where's the hammer michael?
(it's over there?)
Where's the hammer??
woah
(pewds found the glitch)
look, he's been  breaking into his house here..
(prepare for jumpscare)
He's so stupid
look at him..
OH!
JESUS
CHRIST!
You never know what the fuck he's gonna do!!
(SHORYUKEN!)
Wut!
WTF!!
WHAT IS THIS??
Oh.. Come on!!
Mike, you were supposed to help me..
(i tried to be)
I
HAVE
RE-
-TURNED
never
in my 84 y-
i mean
in my 6 years of being on Youtube
have i been this pissed at a game
that's not true
I challenged this game
I'm gonna beat this game
no matter WTF I do..
I'm Fucking pissed!
now apparently, He learns
He learns my movements
and he will know what to expect
so i will give him
THE UNEXPECTED
it's time
here we go
a'right, there he is
SEE, THERE'S THE KEY!
THERE IS DA KEY!
we gotta distract him
plant,
GO!(I CHOOSEEYOU)
(it's not very effective)
(pewds doesn't know what to do next)
AWW SHIT!
Why am i so bad
at this fucking game??
jesus
jesus fucking
jesus fucking christ!
*gasp*
FU
FUUUUUU
FUUUUUUCK
FUCK!
FUUUUUUCK!
GOD
DAMMIT!
(after Milion of attempts of
breaking into the neighbors house)
( 1 thing we knew about him playing this game )
(pewds LOVE Beartraps)
FUCK!
NO!
piece of shi-
(the face of defeat)
(the face of defeat, I feel sorry for him)
(the face of defeat, I feel sorry for him, not really)
(the face of defeat, I feel sorry for him, not really..
Fucking Italian neighbor)
He's gone(x1)
He's gone(x2)
He's gone(x3)
He's gone(x4)
I got the key
USE da key!
Use da kee!
Yooos
DA
DA KEEEEE!
Sheeeet!!
Shit!
ok drop the key...
(surprise motherfucker!)
(screams like a girl)
GOD
DAMMIT!!
(rage poods strikes back)
Just
Just want
Just want wifi *cries*
*cries in poods*
MICHAEL!
I HAVE EVERYTHING IT DOESN'T WORK(WoT?)
(you need the key)
WHERE IS THE KEY?!?
(next to the TV)
THERE'S NO KEY!
oh..
wait..
This is it??
Now what?!?
(open it)
I AM!!
(mike is confused)
What do you think i'm doing?!?
WUT?!?
(RAGE POODS)
It's been days.. (more like second)
I haven't been able to finish the game..
(so am I)
I just can't do it!
I just can't!
DO IT!
so were just gonna look up online..
cause i rally wanna know what's in the room..
It HAS to be something good..
4-7-8-5 yeah, that's it..
Oh my god, Here it is!!
Not
Not even
Not even Harry
Not even Harry Potter
*disappointing in poods*
Not even Harry Potter!
Not even
FUCKING
HAIRY
HAIRY POTTER
(poods use "flip the chair")
Do you hear that gabble??
(pls daddy nuuhhh)
Not even FUCKING
Not even FUCKING Harry
Not even FUCKING Harry Potter
RIP GABBLE
(Here we see a swedish guy fucking a CPR dummy)
(and here we see him destroying  a 500 bux dummy)
well, that's a pretty good game
I really enjoyed it
I really enjoyed it (not really)
I think it's a really good game
I think it's a really good game (liar)
I'm really glad, that you guys recommend this really good game
I'm really glad, that you guys recommend this really good game ( I FUCKING HATE THIS GAME! )
Please leave a like
as a
as a thanks
for
(I HATE YOU GUYS)
nothing
(I'm gonna regret this)
there was no-
there was nothing
AND AS ALWAYS
stay awesome bros!